something is lurking in the water do you
see it
[Music]
close calls like this happen with whales
more often than you might expect and
although the people in these videos got
away relatively unscathed there's no
denying that they were just meters away
from being a whale's lunch but what
would happen if they hadn't been so
lucky could a human body survived being
swallowed by a whale has it ever
happened before this is what if and
here's what would happen if you were
swallowed by a whale if you've never
seen a whale up close it's hard to
comprehend just how monstrous they can
really be to put it in perspective the
blue whale is the largest animal on the
planet
its tongue alone weighs as much as an
elephant and it can fit anywhere between
400 and 500 people in its mouth but we
wouldn't have to worry about one of
these guys swallowing us anytime soon
because their Anatomy makes it nearly
impossible instead we should be more
concerned with their smaller cousins
sperm whales in 1891 reports emerged
that a man had been swallowed by one of
these whales and although he lived to
tell the tale he would never be the same
again according to the story James
Bartley was swallowed when a whale
attacked his ship and he wasn't
retrieved until the following day when
the crew found and killed the whale they
quickly brought it on board their ship
and cut it open revealing an unconscious
but very alive James Bartley his face
and arms were bleached white and he was
blind all thanks to the stomach acids of
the whale
however as the years went by people
started poking holes in this story and
questioned whether James had really been
swallowed by a whale I mean wouldn't the
stomach acids do more damage than just
bleaching his skin well with the power
of science we took a closer look and we
quickly discovered that if you get
swallowed by a whale coming back out
with shiny white skin would be the least
of your worries
okay so the first thing you'd have to
worry about once you were swallowed
would be getting shredded to pieces by
the sperm whales impressive set of teeth
each tooth is approximately 20
centimeters long that's about the length
of an average chef's knife and whales
have anywhere from 40 to 50 of these
let's say you're lucky enough to make it
past all of them next you'd begin your
descent down the throat not only would
it be dark and slimy down here but you
also find it hard to breathe due to the
lack of oxygen and an increase in
methane gas as the whales throat muscles
constricted in and out to help force you
down you'd also start to feel
hydrochloric acid beginning to eat away
at your skin I know what you're thinking
we just got into this whale and James
Bartley's story already seems pretty
fishy well you're not wrong but what
would be the fun in stopping now so next
you'd be dropped into the first and
largest of the whales for stomachs you'd
probably be in there for a while but on
the bright side you might have some
light in the form of a bioluminescent
squid or tube being knocked on after
your arrival
sperm whales love neon flying squid
you'd better enjoy this brief light show
because after this you'd just be tossed
from one stomach to the next with the
acids breaking down almost all of your
body until you're just a bunch of bones
being unceremoniously ejected from the
whale's anus so yeah it's pretty safe to
say that there's no way you could be
swallowed whole by a whale and live to
tell the tale sorry James you may have
been able to fool people in the 1890s
but we're on to you now as vast as they
are and as monstrous as they might seem
to us whales actually have no interest
in eating humans and if they could talk
they would probably make a point of
telling us that but that's a topic for
another what if
[Music]